Brady I want to tell you about what
sounds like a totally impossible problem
to solve and in fact by the end of this
little talk it will still be impossible
on the other hand it'll also seem quite
easy
paradoxically and the title of this
little story is powers of two and you're
asked to solve the following problem
you've got to pick four numbers integers
but they can be positive or negative any
integers you want and you want them to
have the property that if you look at
the sums of pairs of them their powers
of two
and you want as many powers of two as
you can
so if you could pick four numbers
who sums the powers of two you could
pick one one one one because the sum of
any two of them is two and so there are
six ways to pick two of them and we get
six powers of two out of this but
there's one other rule I haven't told
you the numbers have to be distinct
see we can't do one one one one
so let's do a simple case let's start
off with two numbers so
if n is one you can't do anything you
can't there are no sums of pairs if
you've just got a single number if
you've got two numbers I'll call the
value a of n as usual if you've got two
numbers you could take them to be one
and three one and three because the sum
of them is four which is a power of two
and there's only one sum you can get
with two numbers and so we've solved it
with two numbers you take one and three
you could have taken three and five it's
not unique but it would give you a
single power of two good okay what about
three numbers
would you care to give me three numbers
Brady that I would add whose sums in
pairs a powers of two three distinct
numbers okay so a pair of two so uh one
two and five yeah not bad
let's make it one three and five because
that does a little better one three and
five how many do we get well one plus
three is four or good uh three plus five
is eight good one plus five is six
doesn't count it's got to be a power of
two that would give two powers of two
can we do better well yes take minus one
three and five now minus one plus three
is two minus one plus five is four and
three plus five is eight aha we got
three by using a negative number we've
got three powers of two and that's the
best you can do obviously with three
numbers you're only three ways to get
sums of two numbers three choose two is
three so that's best possible and it
worked
what about four numbers call them a b c
and d such an A plus b is power two a
plus c
there are six sums of pairs the
conjecture is you can't do it but this
is an open question the best anyone who
looks at this has been able to do is to
get four numbers
so if you take minus three minus one
three and five let's look at what
happens minus three plus five is two
minus one plus three is two these can be
repeated the powers of two you get can
have repetitions they don't have to be
distinct a minus one plus five is four
and three plus five is eight so this set
of four numbers gives you four powers of
two as far as anyone knows that's the
best you can do so I'm going to write
down here four question mark because
this is still an unsolved question yeah
because you could use really whopping
big numbers couldn't you it sounds
impossible doesn't it and it is nobody
knows how to solve this again you could
write a program say for let's call them
a b c and d for a for minus infinity to
Infinity for B for minus infinity to
Infinity make a plus b a power of two
and so on and there are six you could do
we believe you can't do it but it's an
open really hard question or we love
open questions yes
yes this was a problem of Stan wagons
there's a column of problems that's been
run from McAllister College it's in Paul
Minnesota since 1968. it's it's the
problem of the week that's been going on
since then and um stanwagon took it over
in 1993 and he's still running it this
is problem
um one three
problems of the week one three two one
he will send out a copy of the latest
problem to anyone who's interested this
was a problem from earlier this year
pretty nice problem Neil are you the
sort of guy who will see this and spend
an afternoon trying to crack her or do
you just go oh that's a nice problem and
move on or do you sit down with paper
and a pencil and give it some time
depends on the problem sometimes it'll
take over for a week or a month and I
look up and I say my god I've just spent
a month working on that's that problem
and I'm happy to do that this was not
one of them no this was obviously
impossible and actually by the time I
saw the problem he'd sent out the
solution and the the way he phrased the
problem was if you've got 10 numbers how
many powers of two can you get so his
question was a of ten he said I can get
14 to solve the problem give me 14
pounds of two well if possible do better
so when he sent out the solution he said
various people found 14 and a couple of
people found 15. and Rob Pratt proved
that 15 is optimal
15 is optimal
for a of 10. and when I was looking at
this I thought wow that's incredible and
I wrote to Robin they said how on Earth
did you do that and he wrote back and
said no I didn't do it I assumed the
numbers were in a certain range and with
that assumption I could do the search
Rob's a big expert on on linear
programming and this is just his kind of
problem he's an expert on
milp mixed integer linear programming
and there are an enormous number of
problems that he can solve but he could
only solve this he assumed that the
numbers were in some range from A to B
in fact the range that he picked in the
end was if we're looking
for n numbers let's take them in the
range minus n plus three n plus three
so he assumed that each number
was in that range and that that range he
could search and optimize the number of
solutions and he came up with um a
sequence and that sequence is now in the
oeis but the definition it's not
stanwagon's definition
unrestricted numbers it's restricted
them to this range because that's
unacceptable to me Neil because we we
recently did some videos about
expressing numbers as the sum of three
cubes yes and for some numbers to do
that you had to go to incredible length
you had to search into the into sort of
16 or seven digit numbers yes that's a
famous a famous problem of a similar
kind yes so so this what Rob's done here
just restricting it like that just seems
like he hasn't solved the problem at all
no he doesn't claim to have solved it
and yet looking back at what he's done
that probably is the solution
or close to it I'll tell you a bit more
about that in a minute
um did Rob not look at four for you
though to find out what he certainly did
and um and he he found this of course he
couldn't do any better with a much
bigger search maybe not as big as the
sum of three Cube search with numbers
and the billions okay but it's not clear
that would really help actually
I think probably you can't
do better with four numbers let me
continue and look at n equals five if
you can choose five numbers how many
powers of two can you get you can get
let me write down the numbers minus
three minus one three five and eleven
and if I remember correctly that's going
to give us six numbers because we will
get minus three plus five is two minus
three plus eleven is eight minus one
plus three is two minus one plus five is
four minus one plus ten well eleven is
ten no good three plus five is eight
three plus eleven is fourteen no good
five plus eleven is sixteen and that
gives us six numbers as I said they
don't have to be distinct this has two
twos and two eights but that's fine
there are six powers of two with five
numbers and this is the one exception
that he didn't when Rob Pratt wanted to
set limits that he could go out to a
hundred he the limits that he worked
with were some minus n plus three to
plus n plus three and this is outside
his range for this range he found minus
four minus three minus one three five
which gives five numbers whereas this
give six numbers so we believe that a of
five is six question mark and he's gone
out to a hundred so that's that sequence
[Music]
up to n equals five we have plausible
answers okay in fact we have plausible
answers all the way up really up to a
hundred but kind of doubtful it's quite
possible it could be improved once we
get above 10 note 12 points 15 is
probably optimal for 10 numbers you know
10 shoes 2 is 45 instead of 45 we've
only gotten 15 so that's not doing very
well maybe if you were really clever you
could do better and Stan wagon and Rob
Pratt came up with a lower bound the
lower bound that shows you that you can
at least do moderately well in general
had an idea he said
um instead of having Towers let's have
dungeons
let's go down he says we're going to use
the following notation which actually is
in common use I'll let a sub b mean read
a base B